[Applaus]
Die Agenda, die ich heute Abend darlegen werde,
ist keine republikanische oder demokratische
Agenda,
es ist die Agenda des amerikanischen Volkes. Der
Sieg gewinnt nicht für unsere Partei. Der
Sieg gewinnt für unser Land.
In den
Vereinigten Staaten findet ein Wirtschaftswunder statt  und das einzige, was
es aufhalten kann, sind törichte Kriegspolitik oder
lächerliche Partisanenermittlungen. Ich
möchte, dass die Menschen so zahlreich wie möglich in unser Land kommen
, aber sie
müssen heute Nacht legal einreisen. Ich
bitte Sie, unsere sehr gefährliche
Südgrenze davor zu schützen  Liebe und Hingabe
an unsere Mitbürger und an unser
Land. Kein Thema veranschaulicht die
Spaltung zwischen Amerikas Arbeiterklasse
und Amerikas politischer Klasse besser als
illegale Einwanderung, wohlhabende Politiker
und Spender, die auf offene Grenzen drängen, während
sie ihr Leben hinter Mauern und
Toren und Wachen derweil Arbeiterklasse leben
Die Amerikaner müssen den Preis für
die illegale Masseneinwanderung zahlen Stellenabbau
Niedrigere Löhne Überlastete Schulen
Krankenhäuser, die so überfüllt sind, dass Sie keine
erhöhte Kriminalität bekommen können, und ein erschöpftes
soziales Sicherheitsnetz Toleranz gegenüber illegaler
Einwanderung ist nicht mitfühlend, sondern
sehr grausam. Meine Regierung
hat dem Kongress einen vernünftigen
Vorschlag zur Beendigung der Krise an der
Südgrenze vorgelegt  Dazu gehören humanitäre
Hilfe, mehr Strafverfolgung, Drogendetektion
in unseren Häfen, das Schließen von Schlupflöchern,
die den Kinderschmuggel ermöglichen, und Pläne für eine
neue physische Barriere oder Mauer, um
die riesigen Gebiete zwischen unseren
Einreisehäfen zu sichern. In der Vergangenheit haben die meisten Menschen in
diesem Raum für a gestimmt  Mauer, aber die
richtige Mauer wurde nie gebaut. Ich werde
sie bauen lassen. Vor Jahrzehnten schlossen die Vereinigten
Staaten einen Vertrag mit Russland, in
dem wir uns bereit erklärten, unsere Raketenkapazität zu begrenzen und zu reduzieren
Das geht schon seit vielen Jahren so
, deshalb habe ich angekündigt, dass sich die Vereinigten
Staaten offiziell aus
der Intermedia zurückziehen  Atomwaffenvertrag
oder INF-Vertrag haben wir wirklich keine
Wahl, vielleicht können wir ein
anderes Abkommen aushandeln, indem wir China und andere hinzufügen,
oder vielleicht können wir nicht, in diesem Fall werden
wir alle
anderen bei weitem übertreffen und erneuern, bitte ich Sie  Größe zu wählen,
ungeachtet der Prüfungen, denen wir gegenüberstehen,
ungeachtet der bevorstehenden Herausforderungen, wir müssen
gemeinsam vorangehen, wir müssen
Amerika in unseren Herzen an erster Stelle behalten, wir müssen die Freiheit
in unseren Seelen am Leben erhalten, und wir müssen
immer an Amerikas Schicksal glauben, dass eine
Nation unter Gott ist  muss die Hoffnung und
die Verheißung und das Licht und die Herrlichkeit
unter allen Nationen der Welt sein,
danke, Gott segne dich und Gott segne Amerika,
danke
[Applaus]